mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
la politique étant comme chacun sait le
quoi bon le biome fois dacquois est rien
alors voilà rien oui étant comme chacun
de ces deux violons des redingotes
violon dingue de tout français qui se
respecte nous avons nous aussi bien sûr
songer à former un nouveau parti
malheureusement toutes les étiquettes
était prise ou peu s'en faut car il ya
énormément de partis politiques en
france des partis qui ne forme pas tous
obligatoirement d'ailleurs il ne restait
qu'une il ne restait qu'une appellation
et nous avons sauté dessus à pieds
joints car elle nous paraissait convenir
parfaitement au genre de parti politique
que nous avions décidé de fonder puisque
nous avons appelé le parti d'en rire
mais il est bien évident il est bien
évident que toute partie qui se respecte
et c'est le cas du nôtre doit comporter
un programme un compte chèque postal est
une devise la devise elle est très
simple pour tout ce qui est contre et
contre tout ce qui est pour quant aux
comptes chèque postaux ses piles 3 14
116 14,82 deux fois 6e fois cette je
retiens tout ouïe et le programme
oui alors que le programme pour qu'ils
soient plus facilement repris en choeur
dans les écoles des lycées les marchés
de banlieue et des garages
nous avons décidé de le présenter en
musique bien entendu ne pouvions pas
faire appel à n'importe quel compositeur
aussi nous avons demandé au regretté
maurice ravel de nous écrire la musique
de cet hymne du parti d'en rire que nous
allons vous chantez maintenant
accompagné d'ailleurs par le général
jean d'elbée co qui se trouve à la tête
de son piano et sa team sera sans doute
célèbre un jour
musicalement parlant sous le titre de
boléro de ravel
[Musique]
oui nathan parti martine aubry
oui oui c'est le parti de tous ceux qui
n'ont pas pris une partie notre trophée
paris re oui c'est le parti donne tout
ce qu'il aura pris de part son père puis
nous avons pris le parti
oui et c'est parti comme attardé
marty un parti ouvrir ses voeux mardi en
partie notre d'art oui
et c'est le parti de tous ceux qui n'ont
pas pris de papier
puis c'est parti que depuis ce rappeur
ti et j'espère si c'est henri qu'une pas
leur fille soit parti et que notre parti
ce graphique cantine henry qui a fondé
trompeur été enlevé la vie
marty en soirée la soirée on n'a pas de
parti notre parti parti dans les rues
oui c'est le parti de tous ceux qui
n'ont pas pris de mars nous avons placé
nos c'est bien de noter que les salons
d'attenté située au repos
c'est le carton du jour apollo et voilà
que devra pas passer en revue le marché
de 12 mois
de retard et doit reprendre
la beauté des défunts oui mon ami martin
henry oui le mardi dans tout ce qui dans
ma prise de bateaux sont déjà fixés les
ouvriers ont envie se coucher à prendre
aux chandelles des secousses et olemps
pigeons à roucouler faire sauter les
plans un coup très rude épreuve de
thermoplastiques exigé que tous les
volcans str ramener une fois par an en
supprimant les terminus et pour prouver
qu'on est pas j ai emmené tous les
jeunes s'ennuient
ouais les quais notre programme
des programmes 5,6 au parcours des
migrants des jeunes puissance ou le
droit d'y adhérer si notre parti n'a dit
non et c'est ce qui m'a fait part de
marché oui et moi c'est voyager seul cas
notre parti oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]